BUT THERE’S ALSO AN EMOTIONAL
ASPECT THAT’S VERY UNNERVING.
>> Sean: GERALDO AND
DAN BONGINO, THANK YOU BOTH.
NOW TURN TO BREAKING NEWS AND WE
WERE RIGHT WITH MORE SO THAN WE
KNEW.
FEDERAL COURT FILING FROM FLYNN
ATTORNEY, SIDNEY POWELL NOW HAS
ACCESS TO A TREASURE TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS THAT SHOULD SHOCK YOU
TO OUR CORE.
LOOK AT THESE TEXT MESSAGES AND
NOTES RELEASED TODAY.
AUGUST 11, 2016, AND 1 AGENT
REMARKING, AND SOME OF THESE
GUYS WANT A CLINTON PRESIDENCY.
I’M TELLING YOU, IF THIS THING
EVER GETS FREEDOM OF INFORMATION
ACT REQUEST DATA, GUESS WHAT,
THERE WILL BE SOME TOUGH
QUESTIONS ASKED.
THAT DIDN’T STOP THEM AFTER THE
ELECTION, CONSPIRATORIAL NATURE
OF WHAT THEY HAD DONE WITH
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE AND THEY
PURCHASED PROFESSIONAL LIABILITY
INSURANCE.
IT TURNS OUT THEY ACTUALLY
OBTAINED AN INSURANCE POLICY
BECAUSE OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE INSURANCE POLICY THAT
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE
TALKED ABOUT.
THAT’S THE INFAMOUS JANUARY 5TH
MEETING OF THE OVAL OFFICE
BETWEEN OBAMA, BIDEN, YATES,
COMEY AND KLAPPER.
REMEMBER THAT WAS THE MEETING
WHERE OBAMA AND BIDEN LOOK FOR
WAYS TO SET GENERAL FLYNN UP.
BY THE WAY, GET THEIR BEST
PEOPLE ON THE MATTER.
THE ONE AGENT FEAR THE WORST,
THAT THIS WAS A POLITICAL HIT
JOB AT WRITING, TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
WHY DO WE DO THIS TO THIS TO
OURSELVES.
EVEN DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR TALKS ABOUT HOW ODD
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
WRITING OPEN, NOTHING COMES
CLOSE, EVERYTHING BLACK MALE.
THEORETICALLY POSSIBLE BUT NOT
THE STRONGEST THEORY.
ONE AGENT, IT’S GONE DON’T LIKE
GOING BE SOMEONE ON STAFF.
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE WAS NO
WRONGDOING BY GENERAL FLYNN.
IF THEY KNEW IT AND THEY WERE
USING THEM.
TURNING THE SCREWS ON HIM IN A
DESPERATE EFFORT TO GET
SOMETHING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FIRST CANDIDATE TRUMP.
THEY WERE WILLING TO DO THIS TO
AN AMERICAN WAR HERO, IMAGINE
WHAT THEY WOULD DO TO YOU.
THAT’S JUST PART ONE OF OUR
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
THANKS TO SENATOR GRAHAM WHO
WILL JOIN US IN A MOMENT, WE NOW
HAVE IRREFUTABLE EVIDENCE OF
MASS THE FISA COURTMASSIVE FISA
WE NOW KNOW THEY USED THE
STEELE DOSSIER THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR IS A BOOK OF EVIDENCE,
WITHOUT WHICH THEY GET NO FISA
WARRANT AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, AND THAT STEALS DIRTY
DISINFORMATION.
WE NOW KNOW THE SUB SOURCE WAS
NOT ONLY RELIABLE BUT THE FBI
KNEW THIS PERSON WITHOUT ANY
DOUBT FROM DAY ONE.
TO BE A RUSSIAN AGENT, IN FACT
BETWEEN MAY OF 2009 AND MARCH OF
2011, THE FBI WAS INVESTIGATING
THE PERSON.
THEY KNEW FOR TEN YEARS HE WAS A
RUSSIAN SPY.
THAT MEANS THE SOURCE OF THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS A RUSSIAN SPY
AND HILLARY PAID FOR IT ALL.
AND OUR FBI JAMES COMEY WITH THE
ENTIRE TIME.
THE RUSSIAN INTEL OFFICERS WERE
REPORTEDLY VERY CLOSE, AT LEAST